okay so I want to be both careful in
reporting this story to you but I also
don't want to hold back what are some
very strange elements of what we've
learned so far and this is a story about
left-wing attorney Michael avenatti he
has come to I guess we would call it
fame or prominence over the last year or
so he represented Donald Trump's
hush-money mistress stormy Daniels who
was of course involved in one of the one
of the sort of prominent scandals
involving Trump this hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in hush money paid to
her Michael Cohen was involved in that
supposed big dudes intimidating her were
involved in that avenatti was
representing stormy Daniels there he is
also broken news of sexual assault
accusers of Brett Cavanaugh who is the
now newest Supreme Court justice he also
broke video of Tucker Carlson in a
shouting match with a Hispanic member of
Tucker's Country Club and the news as of
last night is that Michael avenatti has
been arrested in Los Angeles for
suspected domestic violence domestic
abuse and I want to go through this sort
of sequentially in terms of what we knew
when because that has a lot to do with
what's weird about this story so we'll
start at the very beginning news breaks
reported by a number of media outlets
that Michael avenatti has been arrested
by LAPD in Los Angeles for domestic
violence against his estranged wife Lisa
story avenatti so at this point knowing
nothing else in the same way that when
women accused Brett Kavanaugh when women
accused Bill Cosby or whoever we should
trust the victims unless and until
there's information that comes out that
makes us doubt the truth of the story is
it possible that a lawyer who has done
so much pro bono work to expose domestic
abusers and sexual assaulters of women
might himself commit domestic assault of
course it's possible and there's no
reason at its face to doubt the
allegations so far no problem
whatsoever Los Angeles Police Department
tweets confirming the arrests so we know
that that part is true they said quote
update we can confirm that Michael
avenatti birth date February 16th 1971
was booked this afternoon on a felony
domestic violence charge his bail is set
at $50,000 so as far as avenatti himself
i've been saying for months that while
he's done some good things i have some
disagreements with him I have never been
a huge fan of his presence in the
Democratic Party milieu I never thought
that the guy ought to run for president
in 2020 which is something that's been
talked about but I can't deny that he's
been an effective operator in many ways
so at this point I'm thinking I have no
particular reason to doubt the
allegations I'm not a huge fan of his
but I recognize good things he's done
not-so-good things that he's done fine
but then very quickly the domestic
assault story starts to get weird
because his estranged wife's lawyer puts
out a statement saying despite media
reports Michael avenatti wasn't arrested
for anything he did to me
this is his estranged wife speaking I
haven't seen him for months and in fact
when we were together
he never was violent period he never did
anything that even approached physical
violence okay that's kind of odd because
it's being reported that he was arrested
for something he did to this woman and
this woman says this has nothing to do
with me meanwhile Michael a vanadis
first wife tweets something pretty
similar saying I've known Michael
avenatti for over 26 years we met when
he was 21
we were married for 13 years Michael has
always been a kind loving father to our
two daughters and husband to me he has
never been abusive to me or anyone else
he is a good man okay so still it wasn't
his most recent wife that is accusing
him of violence his first and second
wives both say he's never been violent
but could he have been violent and have
hit another woman of course he could
have and as always when it's on the left
or right doesn't matter to me
I say we should trust accusers and take
their accusation seriously and
investigate but is there actually an
accuser here starts to become the
question then TMZ which originally
reported that it was a vanadis ex-wife
said you know what we were misinformed
it's another woman who has alleged
domestic assault on michael avenatti our
source says this is TMZ talking our
source says there was a shouting match
outside of a luxury apartment in Los
Angeles security eventually brought the
woman into the building and avenatti
eventually went in yelling she hit me
first now is any of that actually true I
have absolutely no idea right now and
then something even stranger happens if
you can believe it
remember the fake sexual assault
allegations that were concocted about
Robert Muller by this young Trump
supporter named Jacob wall and this
totally fake company called surefire
intelligence these offers were made to
two different women at least two
different women of $20,000 each if they
were willing to make fake allegations
that Robert Muller sexually harassed
them or assaulted them
it completely blew up in their faces the
Surefire intelligence twitter account
tweeted last night a link to the
avenatti arrests with the message
surefire intelligence strikes again
apparently meaning to imply that they
may have been involved in getting
Michael avenatti arrested if they did do
this why would they admit it I have no
idea
none of Jacob walls actions have ever
made sense to me
but could someone knowing that
California has this mandatory arrest
policy for domestic violence calls could
this all be a right-wing plot to get
avenatti back for his activism it's
definitely possible the next step is we
need a specific and actual accuser where
we say this is the person making the
allegations because right now all we
know Pat is that the accuser that was
initially named in the report denies
that they had anything
to do with it and that Michael avenatti
did anything to them so for me pat its
yeah trust victims but who's the victim
here is there actually a victim yeah and
that's why at least now we want to
reserve judgment but notice how we're
saying that we want to investigate and
get to the bottom of this find out who
the actual victim is contrast that to
the right-wingers when one of them gets
in trouble for domestic abuse or sexual
assault sexual misconduct they don't
want to have the investigation a guy
like Brett Kavanaugh even though he was
accused of attempted rape just push him
on to the Supreme Court we don't have to
look into his background that's exactly
right and so right now we know that an
initial incorrect report about a vanadis
ex-wife being the victim was retracted
and as of right now again by the time
you listen to this by the time you watch
this maybe we'll have more information
there is no actual victim that we know
about and we have a really sketchy
organization with a history of trying to
fabricate sexual assault allegations
against public figures seen as
adversarial to the right I don't say
people on the left coz robert muller is
a lifelong republican people seen as
adversarial to the right and they posted
a strange strange message sort of
seeming to take credit for something
related to the story the story as we
know it right now is that and I'm sure
that Republicans are going to say until
we have definitive evidence that Michael
avenatti did this we have to assume he's
innocent right because that's what they
said with Brett Kavanaugh although I'm
having a little trouble finding those
comments online from right-wingers when
I look for them today's program was made
possible in part by Blink esteem /
Pakman I love bling cast it's the really
perfect app for anybody who likes
politics and learning and if you're
watching or listening to the David
Pakman show I'm sure you love politics
and learning and what blinka studs is
take the best and most popular
non-fiction books they condense them
into 15 minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting and you can
learn about politics philosophy
psychology economics often we don't have
the time to actually read as many books
as we would like I know that I'm at my
limit for how much I can read and this
way you can absorb the most
Orton valuable information from books in
just 15 minutes maybe on your way to
work maybe on your way to the gym maybe
cooking vegan recipes at home whatever
is your thing and our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blinka
scon slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it and I think you will
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for just about 5
bucks a month you can go to be li NK is
t.com slash PA k ma n to sign up